in buffalo a grand jury has indicted the
suspect in the racist killing of ten
black people at a supermarket there
payton gendron appeared in court
yesterday for a short hearing attended
by some relatives of the victims streeka
duncan was also there at the court
drinka good morning
good morning you know it couldn't have
been easy for the victim's family in
that courtroom yesterday as for gendron
he remains behind bars this morning
being held without bail after pleading
not guilty and you know we've been here
all week tony gail and nate and for a
lot of these families that we've spoken
to the question is not about why this
happened uh their question is to white
supremacists why do you hate us so much
we just want to live in peace my
grandchildren are here her great
grandchildren my children i'm scared for
them
family members of the 10 people
massacred at a buffalo supermarket
called on the country to confront and
stop racist violence
that
racist
young man
took
my mother away
she was my best friend
what am i to do
what am i supposed to do now
the eldest daughter of 86 year old
victim ruth whitfield struggled for
words the night of the shooting they
were supposed to see a musical together
i need this
violence to stop
we need to fix this and we need to fix
it now
12-year-old jake patterson who lost his
father hayward patterson kept his face
covered with his hands as his mother
described how he's now having trouble
eating and sleeping
as a mother what am i supposed to do
to help him get through this
i need a village to help me
raise and be here for my son
because he has no father
thursday morning the accused gunman 18
year old peyton gendron made a brief
court appearance he's been charged with
murder in the first degree and
prosecutors say he could face hate crime
and domestic terrorism charges
peyton you're a coward
jerome wright is a deacon at a local
church who has been offering support to
the grieving families he says meaningful
change goes beyond getting justice for
saturday's attack this community is
hurting and grieving and mourning and
though the
gunman may have been
apprehended the killer white supremacy
institutional and internalized racism is
still on the loose
and today is that first funeral for
hayward patterson as for this grocery
store behind me
we're told that it will reopen the
president of top said that yesterday at
a news conference as for when that will
happen they don't have an actual
timeline for that gail
that's not comforting either jerica
thank you so much